>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Good morning.
My name is Jennifer Harbster.
I am a reference and research
specialist with the science,
technology and business division
here at the Library of Congress
for two more weeks [laughs].
And as she said I'm going
to UC Davis and I am going
to do their astronomy
and physics out there.
So you can't take me
away from astronomy.
I'd like to welcome
you to today's program,
New Horizons Journey
to Pluto and Beyond.
This is our final program
of the 2015 series presented
through a partnership
between our division
and NASA Goddard Space
Flight Center.
And next year will be
our ten year anniversary.
So, yea. It's my pleasure to
introduce today's speaker,
Dr. Dennis Reuter, an astrophysicist
with an emphasis I'll have
to say on planetary studies.
He is also co-investigator
for the New Horizons mission
and the instrument scientist
for Ralph, a color imager
and infrared spectrometer on
the New Horizons spacecraft.
Now pairing with Ralph
is another instrument
on New Horizons called Alice.
We will better understand
the composition of Pluto
and other objects in the
Kuiper belt by Alice and Ralph.
And, yes, scientists have a
great sense of humor [laughs].
So I'm not sure if you caught the
Ralph and Alice pairing [laughs].
If you did not, it is
a [laughs] reference
to the 1950s TV show,
"The Honeymooners."
Dr. Reuter received his
undergraduate degree in chemistry
from the Rensselaer Polytechnic
Institute or RPI and his doctorate
in physical chemistry
at UC Berkeley.
He has been at NASA since the 1980s
and has received numerous
exceptional achievement awards
for his work and he also has
an asteroid named after him.
Asteroid 4706 is Dennis Reuter.
[ Laughs ]
I think [laughs] I was like,
I think I want a job like that
where I get an asteroid
named after [laughs] me.
Before New Horizons Dr. Reuter was
a laboratory scientist studying
spectra of earth in space using
heavy equipment in his lab.
And then he began to
develop spectral instruments
for robotics space
exploration missions,
and I think we have a
little bit of show and tell
of some stuff that
is on New Horizons.
He's also or has been
involved in five space missions
and among them are Landsat eight
and nine, New Horizons of course,
and Osiris Rex, which
is super exciting,
if you haven't heard
about this mission.
It's set to launch in September
of 2016 to the asteroid Bennu.
The mission will bring samples
from Bennu back to earth
and that will be in 2023 maybe.
So we'll have to schedule
[laughs] [inaudible].
Hopefully next year we can have
someone to come and from NASA
and talk about Osiris Rex.
Today we'll learn about
the New Horizons mission
and explore the Kuiper
belt in an area of space
that we haven't had a chance
to look up at closely before.
Dr. Reuter is going to highlight
some of the close-up images
of the Pluto system and talk
about the science behind it.
These high resolution images
told incredible stories
and help created a lot of excitement
in the scientific community
and the public.
They're going to help us understand
the composition of the bodies
of the Kuiper belt and how
those compositions vary,
but they're also going to help
us better understand the origins
of the solar system.
So let's get to the Kuiper belt
and learning about New Horizons
and join me in welcoming Dr.
Reuter to the Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
>> Well, thank you very much and I
guess I should say that I'm lucky
to be the last one because
[inaudible] so it sounds
like everything is
going to go to heck.
Okay. As she said I'm Dennis Reuter.
Now I'm a co-investigator
on the Pluto mission.
There's roughly 25 or
so science [inaudible],
but there's a larger group of
people working on it, collaborators.
I'm going to, as you see we'll talk
about the results we're getting,
but I will talk a little bit
about the instrumentation because,
you know, that's my thing.
But when I'm giving this
talk, please bear in mind
that everything you're
saying really depends
on the efforts of a huge team.
The people who built
the instruments,
the people who built the spacecraft,
the people who ran the spacecraft
who actually planned the
operations then we get there.
You know, the companies
that made the components.
This is sort of a national
type effort.
And it's common for these type
of missions that, you know,
we have contributions
from all over the country,
university, government, industry.
So I'm very privileged to be part of
this and I thank you for funding it.
[Laughs] Now, New Horizons
it completes the exploration
of the classical solar system and
I'll get to that in a little bit.
But, you know, we've gone
through all the planets.
Now, there's still a lot to
learn from all the planets.
Every time we go to Mars
we learn something new.
Every time we go to someplace
else we learn something new.
I'm sure when we go to Bennu we're
going to learn something new.
And we have an instrument on
Bennu that's kind of based on, or,
excuse me, on Osiris
that's kind of based
on the technology we
developed for New Horizons.
But now we're sort of we
finished that just sort
of initial exploration part.
Now we can really go back and
start looking at everything
in more detail and
as we already are.
But perhaps we'll start
to look a little bit more
in detail the farther out
parts of the solar system.
And that's what New Horizons also
did was it started the exploration
of that part of the solar system.
Now this is a area that has been
around since the beginning
of the solar system.
It's very pristine, it
hasn't been near the sun,
so it hasn't been affected
by the various things
that the sun puts out.
Very pristine material,
so if you want to go
and see what the solar system was
like 4 1/2 billion years ago, well,
that's a good place to go
because it really is maintaining
that character.
The closest approach
was just this last July.
It turns out that happens to be my
wedding anniversary also, July 14.
[ Laughs ]
>> So my wife is very understanding.
I appreciated that very much
because we were not at home.
[ Laughs ]
>> It also is the 50th anniversary
of the first transmission
of pictures from a spacecraft,
Mariner 4 from a planetary.
So it's kind of fitting that way.
And the results, as you'll see,
demonstrate why it's important,
it's very important to have
the ground-based observations.
You know, you spend time.
You can go out, you can look
at things for quite a while.
They just add a huge amount to our
understanding, but until you get
up to the thing and say, "Oh my
goodness look at that little spot
over there," you really
don't understand the thing
and that's what going to these
moons or these systems are like.
And Pluto helped.
Pluto could have been
just sort of boring.
It decided to be an incredibly
diverse and exciting object.
And, you know, it's a rock star.
I supposed I should
say it's a rock ice.
[ Laughs ]
>> Because or it's an
ice star, I should say.
It's cold out there.
Well, the mission history,
the first concept
for what eventually became New
Horizons was put forth by Alan Stern
and other folks who were on the New
Horizons team back in about 1989.
In fact, he gave a
talk at Goddard talking
about a possible Pluto mission.
And there were a whole
bunch of iterations.
Somebody was asked earlier there is
a iteration where there were going
to be two spacecrafts,
because when we fly
by Pluto has a six-day rotation
period and so when you get
up close you're going to see
whichever side you're close to.
Well, if you want to see both sides
really good, you have one go by
and then another one
go by three days later.
Well, that would have
been nice, but, you know,
it's expensive and
da, da, da, da, da.
And so things would come
and go and come and go.
We got involved at Goddard
back in about 1993 or so,
because one thing that's
characteristic for all these is
that you want really light
instrumentation that's very capable,
because in order to get out to Pluto
you want to go fast and to go fast
that means you just can't
have a whole lot of mass,
so you want to have
light instrument.
And I'll show you, you know, sort
of the size of our instrument.
You'll understand why it's light.
But the New Horizons mission
was eventually proposed
and the proposal accepted
in November of 2001.
So that's when we really
started on this.
Now, 2001 to 2006 sounds like
five years, but to go from, "Oh,
I don't have anything to here,
I've launched it," that's a lot
of work to do in five years.
So this is a very intense
period of time.
It was also the first of the
new frontiers class of mission,
which is also with Osirus Rex.
Yes, it's a sort of the largest
principal investigator type mission
there is.
Launch was from Cape
Canaveral in 2006.
It was the fastest thing
ever to leave the earth.
That picture I had up at
front was of the launch
and it was like, oh, there it goes.
I mean it was -- and it was cloudy,
so, you know, the whole launch
that you could see things was very
short, but it was very exciting.
You know, the Jupiter fly by in
February, 2018, so basically,
you know, 12 months, 13 months
after launch we're at Jupiter.
Well, usually it takes
years to get there.
It took us nine hours
to get to the moon.
You know, the Apollo
took [inaudible].
It's moving fast, right.
Again, because you
want to get there.
Now, Jupiter we got a gravity
assist got us out to Pluto faster,
but we also got to practice the type
of things that we're going to do
at Pluto and we got some science
out that people hadn't seen before.
There were publications on
it, it was very exciting.
We crossed Neptune's orbit just, you
know, about a year and a half ago
and got there at, you know,
on started to take data
that was higher resolution,
higher spatial resolution
than ever been taken
before in the May time frame
and then obviously the
closest approach is just blows
everybody away.
So there's our solar system.
We're all used to the
four inner planet.
We live on one.
We all know about the
forge gas giants.
Those were the ones who were
visited by Pioneer and Jupiter.
The asteroid belt, well that's,
you know, small particles
or small objects kind of like what
you see out at the Kuiper belt,
but they've been enclosed
since they've been, you know,
things have happened to them.
And now we get to Pluto.
And Pluto is at the
edge of the Kuiper belt.
That's that new zone that's
of the pristine material
and that's what we want to be
studying now in the future.
And I'll talk a little
bit about that.
So the Kuiper belt, there
is sort of a spherical cloud
of objects called the
[inaudible] cloud and that's been
around forever, but it's way out.
The Kuiper belt is flat,
kind like the solar system is
when things were condensing down
the whole system condensed down
and then the planets would
go and make, you know,
themselves out of that material.
Well, the Kuiper belt
did the same thing,
but it tended to make
smaller objects.
And so those things
were still there.
Pluto is very large
for the Kuiper belt.
We've only found one that
may or may be not be larger.
You know, since it's hard to
tell, you see a speck of light
and you sort of say, well, I'm
going to tell you how big it is,
how bright that is and
how far away it is,
but then if the surface reflects
more light than you might expect,
then suddenly you've got a
connection between the size
and how bright the surface is.
So they're assumptions that
are made, but Pluto and Eris is
about the same size, but much larger
than most other objects out there.
So here's our prime target.
Now, when we were proposing
this it was Pluto and Charon,
it's moon that was
found in about 1967.
Pluto itself was of course
discovered by Tombaugh, excuse me,
in 1930 by looking at pictures
flashing them back and forth
and trying to see that one
little spot that moved.
I'm glad he did it.
I wouldn't want to do
it, but in any rate
when we were first proposing
it was Charon and Pluto.
By the time we launched
there was a Nix in the Hydra.
By the time we got there, there
were four, five moons Charon, Nix,
Hydra, Kerberos and Styx.
And, you know, this again was
found by ground-based observations,
but now as we were going out,
suddenly we're changing our design
because there's these objects
out there we didn't know about.
We want to include them
in our observation.
So it tells you that the process
of designing the encounter
was continual in launch.
This is a relative
size of the thing.
So Pluto, that's the big guy,
but it's still pretty small
and then the little guys
are really quite little.
All right.
But they're still important.
They still maintain, they have
information about the system,
about what went on out there.
Some of them are rotating
around really quickly.
They're not what we expected.
By the way, nothing
is what we expected.
Our mission objectives.
Well, I can go through
each of these.
We had the group one objectives.
Those are the things
that you had to do.
And the group two objectives,
those were the things
that you really wanted to do,
but if it meant you
couldn't do a group one,
you didn't do a group two.
And the group threes are
those things that you do
if you have a chance, right.
But basically what they come
down to is [inaudible] understand
what does the surface look like?
What is the surface made of?
How does the surface
interact with the atmosphere?
Pluto has an atmosphere, it would
not be much if you went out there.
You wouldn't feel, you
know, it's about a millionth
of the earth's atmosphere, but
it's there and it's supported
by stuff coming off the surface.
So there's still transport going on?
The same type of processes
that go on the earth except
at 40 kelvin considering that
nitrogen freezes at about 50 kelvin,
you can kind of get the idea what it
would be like if we were on Pluto,
there would be no air here
and we would just be stuff
on the ground, right.
Nice. We look at -- oh, I'm sorry.
>> That's okay.
>> We look at the ionosphere.
We look at the ions.
We've chosen the instruments
to really be able
to sample the entire characteristics
of the atmosphere, the surface.
We even use the radio communication
to get the idea of the mass
and we can look at the surface and
see how much power it's putting
out in the microwave, and that
tells us what the temperature is.
We can also use the
infrared to get the measure
of the temperature in
an interesting way.
I'll talk about a little bit.
So we're trying to understand the
system as if it were, you know,
as if it were the earth, right.
I mean this is the type of thing
you'd want to know about a planet.
So the spacecraft, it's about the
same size as a baby grand piano
and you saw it sitting on a
rocket that's 300 feet tall
and there's just this
little tiny thing
up there going out
as fast as it can.
Its powered by a plutonium reactor.
Now, it just really makes it warm
and it generates electricity.
The problem is that Pluto you've got
roughly a thousandth of the amount
of light that's in the sun
as you do here, so, you know,
you really can't generate much
power or you need a, you know,
a kilometer size solar cell to do so
and it's a little hard
to get that out there.
So the instrument compliments.
So, again we have Lorri, which
is a high resolution imager.
And then we have MVIC and Leisa and
those are the components of Ralph
and it's a moderate resolution
imager, but it also has colors.
That's what MVIC is and then
Leisa is the spectrometer.
It's the thing that
looks in the infrared
and when light strikes an object,
parts of some of its wavelengths
gets absorbed and those wavelengths
that are absorbed tells you
what the materials made out of
and that's why we looked
on the infrared.
It tells us what the
material is on the surface.
The GV spectrometer,
that's primarily for looking
at the atmosphere and then there
are these particles SWAP and Pepssi,
which are plasmid instruments.
They're looking at the solar wind
and also the heavier
ions that are at Pluto.
And then there's a student
instrument called the Venetia Burney
Student Dust Counter.
And that was added at the end
and it was very successful,
but basically what it does is it
looks for particles hitting it,
and counts how many there are.
So you get a measure of how many
dust particles are out there.
This is what the spacecraft
looks like.
It's that little thing
up at the top.
This thing underneath is the third
stage rocket and that goes on top
of the spacecraft and this all fits
into this little area on the top
of that thing that you
saw was much larger.
The spacecraft they separate,
you know, after a launch,
and actually this guy
went to Pluto too.
The rocket engine, it
doesn't have anything on it.
We just know it followed around.
But here's the eyes and ears.
Usually you don't talk about
things having sound and space,
but like I said, the
dust counter really looks
at things hitting it,
so it's kind of an ear.
It's kind of motion of something.
There's Ralph and Ralph
is about this big
and I'll show you a picture of that.
There's the Ralph instrument.
And this is what's
interesting about it.
It's two spectrometers in one.
Its two cameras in one.
The optics in front feed two
focal planes, two detectors,
kind of like what you have
in your cell phone, you know,
for taking pictures, but the
infrared one is sensitive
to infrared light and this
is stuff that was done back
in the early 2000s, so
it's not as high tech now.
We had a 256 squared
array JWST is going
to have 4,000 pixel squared arrays,
you know, so things have changed,
but this is what we
were working with.
This is the spectrometer
that's on Ralph.
It's the Leisa spectrometer.
[ Laughs ]
>> That gives you an idea of what
I'm saying is and this was a concept
that Don Janes and I came up with
and a lot of other as we found
out later, came up with also.
But you basically put this
in front of the detector
and the wavelength changes
as you go along here.
So a given [inaudible] only
sees a given wavelength, right.
You kind of see this.
This is actually not the
material that we use.
It's sort of an engineering
version just the people made to show
that they could make the codings.
But actually I have some
that if you look at lights
and stuff you could see the
rainbow, and if you look
at florescent light you can actually
see the atomic lines coming out.
Okay, so we have both of
these things going on.
By the way, everything that's done
on the spacecraft we don't have any
mirrors moving around or anything.
The spacecraft has to move to look
at things, so if you want to look
at Pluto you look there, and
then if you want to look at one
of the moons you look over here
and then you look back here.
And then, you know, so this is
the type of planning that goes on.
Now, on the closest approach
day, you know, two days before
or three days before,
okay, we look at Pluto.
We'll scan it, great.
You know, move around and
look at the other ones.
On the closest approach day it's
like, okay, I got to do this.
We're moving a lot and
I'll show you a movie
that actually shows what we did.
You would be amazed actually.
I am. Again, this is
the spectrometer,
so this is the visible one.
I forgot to bring the pointer.
I always do that.
Here, this is he visible one.
[ Laughs ]
>> And it's like long CCD arrays,
so they're, like, 5,000 pixels wide
and then this is our
infrared, 256 by 256.
And this is a filter on top of it.
There are actually two segments.
There's a higher resolution,
higher spectra resolution segment
and a lower spectra
resolution segment
and this higher spectra resolution
has a really cool application.
I will explain in a little bit.
Okay, so this is the composition
information that we've got,
the four visible filters.
We get the color out of
that, but we also have one
that looks at a band of methane.
So it gives us complimentary
information to Ralph/Leisa
which looks at a whole
bunch of bands of methane.
A whole bunch of absorption
features of nothing.
And this is the characteristics and
basically what its saying is there's
about 250 colors, if you
will, in the infrared
that we looked at in
the visible part.
Now, the high resolution,
that's nitrogen absorbs.
You know, I mean it's not a strong
absorber, but if you put, you know,
meters of nitrogen, solid
nitrogen on the surface.
And it's kind of what Pluto has,
it gets weak absorption features.
Turns out that the shape of that
absorption feature is determined
by what the temperature of the
ice is and that's what we use
that little high resolution
segment for.
So we're actually using spectroscopy
to tell us the temperature
of something that there's no
way we could get, you know,
the amount of radiation
coming at 2.5 microns
from a 50K source is zero.
Which is nothing coming out, but
we can see from the visible --
from the reflected solar
light what the temperature is
by looking at the spectrum.
Remember, well I give you an idea.
These are the type of resolutions
we're getting, so they're kind
of on the order of a
kilometer per pixel or better.
In fact, Lorri gets down to
ten times better than this
at some positions, but it
doesn't get the whole surface.
That's why we had to do sort
of this combination of things,
but getting down to
less than a kilometer
on an object that's been seen
at, I'll X that in a second,
but much lower resolution
is very important.
Now this is our mission profile.
Again, we launch in 2006, we go by
Jupiter, get the gravity assist.
We get out to Pluto,
Charon and now, you know,
we're looking out as we go
along and there's another chance
that we'll be able to
do another observation
of another type of an object.
I'll explain that a little bit
at the end, but it's not part
of the plan yet, but we're
trying to propose it a little.
Well, that first image is
what you saw from the ground.
That's the best image that we
had of Pluto before we launch.
That's from the Hubble actually,
it's not from the ground,
you know it's our best thing.
That's what we get when
we get close to Pluto.
That's the heart feature
that we reported so often.
And even at the heart feature,
now you can see that,
hey they do correspond.
I mean, where the part feature
is it is a little brighter,
where the dark areas
is, it is darker.
But, boy, you really don't see the
resolution that you get at that.
And that's not the resolution.
We actually get higher than that.
I just, you know, I have to have
a picture that fits on the screen.
And I will show you some
higher resolution things.
So this is what you
get by going someplace.
All right.
This is the ground and then you get
out there and you see this and all
of a sudden you're saying,
"Well, goodness gracious,
there's things all over the
place here that are different."
And this is, you know,
when you put the colors in,
you start seeing composition
and so on.
So here is some New
Horizons results.
We didn't have any idea what we
were going to see when we got there.
When we got there what we
saw was not what we expected.
I know it sounds odd, but, you know,
you kind of expect, well, okay,
it will be a solid feature.
It will look kind of like the
asteroids there was something light.
No. I mean, basically
every time you get an image
down somebody is saying, what
the heck or to that effect --
[ Laughs ]
>> -- is that image, you know.
It's just been amazing the
type of things we're finding.
We see things and it's not, oh,
yea, I understand that its --
golly, that doesn't seem to make a
lot of, you know, because now all
of a sudden you're trying
to understand things
that we've never seen before.
Very diverse surface, evidence
of dynamic processes
including nitrogen flow.
Solid nitrogen flow, I
mean kind of think of that.
It boggles the mind that we're
talking about processes that happen
on earth, but they're
happening at 40 kelvin on things
that are solid nitrogen
and solid CO and mixed
with solid methane, you know.
A lot of different surface
compositions are evident
and they're connected to
the geology and so on.
Atmosphere with multiple haze
there, who expected that?
It's got a blue sky.
Yeah, I expected it was going
to have a blue sky, right?
On and on and on and the first
paper that came out in sciences,
if you're interested,
it's an excellent paper.
And I would, you know, if
you're interested in finding
out the real details that
would be a good place to go.
Now, I'm going to talk
and the pictures
that are coming are going
to be in more detailed.
I'm going to use place names.
They're informal, they're not agreed
to by the IAU or anything like that,
so, you know, just
keep that in mind.
Now, there's Pluto and Charon in
color and you notice right away
that Charon looks kind of smooth,
except there's this weird
little red spot on top.
Where the heck did that come from?
Oh, it looks like it's
possibly in a depression.
Does that mean that
Charon has been hit?
Maybe. You know, there's
this area on Pluto.
Well, look there's
craters all over the place.
Over here and over here
and there, its flat.
What's going on there?
You tell me, we'll all know.
[ Laughs ]
>> So, you know, we have theories,
but is that a surface
that's being refurbished
or is there something
coming up from underneath.
This is the image we took
as we left the thing.
Look at that.
I mean, you know, this is --
there's hazes in the atmosphere.
This looks like what you'd see, you
know, if you looked at the arctic
in the earth, right, mountains.
That's a very dynamic thing.
It's not kind of what we expected,
three kilometer tall mountains
next to flowing glaciers.
Sure. Now, as you get to the edge
of where the light is hitting,
you know, you start to get effects
that are showing you the height
of certain objects, because
now light is coming along
and it hits the mountain
that's up here.
Well, now it makes
a shadow behind it.
Those are called crepuscular rays.
You see these in the
earth all the time.
You go out and look in the sky
and you'll see these little
spots of rays of light.
It's the type of thing
that's causing this --
usually maybe it's a cloud that's in
a way that's not letting light go by
and you see light from
the other areas.
But, yeah, you can see this.
There's light coming in and
now it's this shadow behind it.
Now, this helps us tell
how high the thing is.
But it also tells us, again,
this is a very interesting world.
Why is Pluto red?
Well, one of the things that people
have talked about is tholins.
And basically tholins are you take
methane and CO and nitrogen and you,
you know, throw solar radiation
and radiation from, you know,
hydrogen lines and cosmic
rays at it for a billion years
and it [inaudible] its
chemistry to happen
and you get basically gunk, right.
But the gunk has colors and that's
what we think is going on here.
But you'll notice that, again,
there's that region over here
with the crater with also very
interesting other features that's
lots of craters and then there's
this flat area and it's light,
and the other stuff
is sort of reddish.
And, you know, really indicates that
something different is going on.
So this is that area over there.
We think its older,
darker, it's been,
you know, we can see the craters.
We think it's been more processed
than this Tombaugh Regio.
Again, you know, informal
names, but obviously named
after the discovery of fluid.
You know, a nice bright
feature that's crater free.
Now, we'll start to look
at some specific areas
of this Tombaugh Regio.
First, we'll look at number one.
That's ice flow.
You look up there.
Look at that.
Nitrogen flying around mountains
and it's what you'd see in Alaska,
if Alaska were 300 kelvin colder.
[ Laughs ]
>> When we wouldn't want that.
But you're also seeing
a polygonal cell.
What are those things?
Well, maybe they're
convection cells.
Okay, but not what we expected
and you know we're still
- these are possibilities.
We still have to link all
the various pieces together
to get a full story, but this is the
type of information we're getting
out from this and this says
this is a very active system.
This is at the bottom of that area
between where you're
getting the cratered surface
and where you're getting
this new surface.
Well, is that because the
cratered surface is --
the new surface is going backwards
and its leaving the crated surface
behind or is the new surface going
down and covering up
the crater surface?
You know, again, lots
of possibilities.
That's the type of thing
we're going to be looking
at for the next -- well, let's see.
The next time Pluto will be where it
is now is about 200 years from now.
So people are looking
[laughs] you know, 200 years.
I mean people are still looking at
the data that came out of Voyager
and Pioneer and we've
set things back
to the objects that they studied.
It's going to be a while before
something goes back to Pluto.
[Inaudible], you know,
it could always help.
Now, we have this area
of what we call Chaos
and what we think these are.
These are mountains of
ice floating in nitrogen,
so nitrogen is a little bit more
dense than ice at 50 kelvin.
And, you know, if there's
some heat process going
on underneath, which
we don't know yet.
You know, that would kind of explain
what's going on here, but we, again,
we see the interface between the
mountains, the sciatic region,
the cratered region and that flat
area over there, which, you know,
something's coming
up from the surface.
If its convection and
stuff that's coming up then
that surface is continually
being refreshed.
We don't see it because it
keeps covering the craters
or some big event has happened.
Right. We're getting a snapshot
in time of something that's been
around for four billion years.
If you look at me 55 years ago I
will bet you don't say, oh, yeah,
that's what he's going to
look like in 60 years or so.
Anyway, you know, so it's
challenging and its part
of what makes the interpretation
interesting.
Now, the color images, now you
look at these and you're starting
to see well now there's specific
colors that are associated
with the various types of
geology you're seeing, right.
In other words, the composition
is different than those areas
that look kind of different if
you looked at them in panchromatic
in sort of a broadband spectrum.
Well, again, now we're learning
that other things are going on.
Is that places where there's been
more processing or is that places
where this stuff that was
processed was knocked off?
You know, again, you can always
have two observation per region.
Now, you can kind of look at
things and say, well, gosh,
that kind of looks like
what you see on the earth,
and you see glacial
islands and Antarctica.
And we see a little glacial
island there and by the way,
there's streaks coming
out over here.
They sure look like wind streaks.
Again there is wind.
It's not high, you know, but, again,
over millions of years this is the
type of thing that might happen.
I don't know yet, that's one
of our processes going forward.
The heat flow, again, you
know, the heat flow is what,
2% of what it is on
the earth, right.
You know, it's not a
very strong heat flow.
Is it making these things?
Maybe the gravity is much lower.
Do we have cryovolcanoes?
Now, we didn't see anything.
Titan has often been chosen as
sort of Pluto's brother closer in
and when we went by
Titan we saw, you know,
nitrogen geysers coming up.
That's really cool.
Well Titan is next to Neptune.
There's a tidal force
that can drive energy.
And there's nothing really
here that's next to this.
You know, Charon is
there, but its small.
It shouldn't have that much
of a driving force in terms
of tidal driving, but
you look at these things
and they look like volcanoes, right?
There's this vent and these
are sort of saying [inaudible],
and its surrounded
by an area that looks
like something came up
and formed a volcano.
You don't see this, but
it's very, very suggestive.
This was just weird.
[ Laughs ]
>> I mean, you know,
the surface is stripe.
This is what we called
the snake's skin surface
if you follow it around.
Again, I'm sure there's an
explanation for it, and,
you know, that's what we look at.
But when we saw this
people just said "Okay,
somebody's playing around."
Right.
[ Laughs ]
>> it's very strange and we've
gotten some three dimensional things
and you go look at these and
you can see very nice three
dimensional structure.
Now, we get to the parts that
is the compositional part.
This is what we get
from the infrared.
This is what we going to
relate to the structure.
This is one of the first
spectra we got using Leisa.
And there are two different
wiggly lines
and those wiggly lines show you
where light is being absorbed
in very narrow bandwidths.
And you can see it's
quite different.
There's this nice little flat thing.
This is a methane feature,
methane does.
Methane those that too.
So it looks there's nothing here,
but there's something else as well.
Okay. That can happen when
you mix stuff together
or maybe there isn't methane there.
You know, again we're
interpreting these things.
I'll tell you about the data.
But this is cool because I
think this is the first spectrum
that was ever shown on the
Jumbotron at Times Square.
[ Laughs ]
>> This is, you know, you
just don't see that too often.
All right.
Well, now we start to
look at other things.
Water. Well, this is
odd, here's water.
This nice little street
there, not much there.
Remember that mountainous area
over there that we think is water.
Mountains we don't see the water in
the mountains, we see it around it.
Now, what that means is that when we
say there's water there we're seeing
pure water spectrum.
Now, if you look at that
first spectrum I show you,
remember there was the one that
was very characteristic of methane
and there was one that was not,
well, there's still probably methane
in both, but it's other stuff
is either on top of it or mixed
in with it, and it doesn't
look like pure water.
These look like pure water, they
look basically what Charon looks
like and Charon is pretty
much pure water except
for I'll shows it's not.
Again, what's going
on in the surfaces?
Is the surface producing water
there that is getting covered over
or is that an area that was
covered over and something came
and knocked it off and now
we're seeing the water again.
Here's methane ice absorption.
Now, this is just the
absorption from Leisa.
So you're not seeing any
of the visible images,
but you see features there and if
you put that over a Lorri image
at high resolution now you see
that, oh, look, this stuff,
flew out of methane in
that spot like plantum,
which is where that flat area was.
Methane is volatile.
It's something that at Pluto
temperatures evaporates kind of.
It takes a while, but you don't see
the methane over in this region,
where the craters are and it's very
correlated with structural features.
Same thing for nitrogen, right.
Again, you see that area
right there, that's that area
where there's a lot of
evaporating type material.
But again, not over
in that dark area,
and again associated
with [inaudible].
And again, all these
names are made up.
Same thing with CO. Now
CO is a little noisier,
it's not as strongly absorbing.
We haven't gotten all
the data down yet.
I guess we'll get better as
we get more of the data down
and we can beat the noise down.
But again, you see
its right in that area
where you expect the volatile things
to be, not much over anywhere else.
And then there's water.
Oh, well, no water in
that area over there.
A lot of it over here.
So we're seeing that there's
a correlation in the geometry.
And, in fact, if you remember that
picture I showed around that crater
where they had that little streak of
water, that's this guy right here.
You can see that the
spectra is telling us
about the geometry, geology.
It's very exciting.
But this is not the
only exciting thing.
There's the other moon
out there, Charon.
Again, you know, we
see this structure,
this thing that's more bigger than
the Grand Canyon, sitting down here.
Where did that come from?
I mean, is that something that
happened because something hid
at the top and sort of fractured
things and then it made,
when something hits it's going
to flip the orbital
axis, the rotation axis.
Charon and Pluto are kind of
like the Earth and the Moon,
they're tightly locked, so you
always see the same face of Charon
if you were standing on Pluto.
And if you were standing on
Pluto you'd be pretty cold also.
You don't want to do that.
But at any rate, you know,
spectrally it's pretty bland.
It's got water everywhere
except where there's ammonia.
And when there's ammonia, is this
area where there is a crater.
Well, does that mean that
that's a new crater that's gone
down and let the ammonia out?
Or has something been let out that
has formed ammonia after a while?
Is that a new thing?
Is this some way that we
can possible date impacts?
All right.
Again, this combination
of composition
and geology is really telling us a
lot about what's going on, on the,
surface which is an
inactive surface,
something that we hadn't expected.
Or we hoped for but we hadn't
expected it to be this [inaudible].
Now we got the Charon on the small
moons, and basically you're seeing,
you know we don't get as close to
them as we get to Pluto and Charon
because they were the objects
that we were going for.
If you were going to choose whether
you get Charon and Pluto or one
of the small moons, you're
going to go with Pluto,
so we didn't really
move anything around.
We did actually though,
once we started
to see all these moons somebody
said "Oh, wait a minute,"
somebody meaning Alan Sern,
[phonic] does this mean that now all
of a sudden we have to worry about
are we going to hit something.
All right.
So we spend a fair amount of time
doing a lot of modeling saying well
if material is coming off Pluto,
is where we're going safe?
If we start to see something
as we get close and we start
to see a lot more particles,
do we have a way to go
that we can get some place safe?
So, you know, we're still
getting the data down,
so you much rather get less
data, but then get it rather
than get a whole bunch of
data and then hit something
and then get nothing
out of it at the end.
So there was a lot of planning
that went into what we finally did.
Now, it turned out that if
you actually did the modeling,
Charon intended to sweep out
the materials that was up there
and so the probability that there
was anything there was pretty small.
But it took several years
to get us to that point,
several years where you know,
it was a fair amount of angst.
Let's put it that way.
Now this is when we're
living and here's the haze
of Pluto and that's blue.
It really is blue and I mean, you
know, this comes from the meth
from the MVIC observations, and if
you look at Pluto's haze it goes
up hundreds of kilometers in blue.
If you look at it in the
methane channel, which is blue is
about .4 microns and the wavelength
is .4 microns, methane absorption is
around .9 microns, so it's about
2 1/2 times the wavelength of it.
You don't see much, you see haze
but its stops fairly far down.
And again, the fact that
we're seeing these layers,
is that because something is forming
and then coming down and staying
in one place for a while,
while other things occur?
You know, what is that
connected with?
And again, this is the type of work
that goes on over the next few years
as we get more data and as
we learn from that data,
other things about the
surface that can help us point
to what's going on there.
So here's our timeline,
and we're here
in the middle of the
science playback.
We'll do some close encounter
calibrations afterwards,
after the playback is done.
I mean, this is still a time
when we're still sweating things
out because if something happens to
the spacecraft we lose that data.
For example, Leisa, we did,
you know, two very high --
four really high resolutions
-- four high resolutions scans
and one very high resolution scan.
So far we've gone down two
of the high resolutions scan,
so we still have a
lot of stuff there.
We have a whole bunch of
data that we took as we left,
looking through that atmosphere
that maybe we can look in that data
and see what's in the atmosphere
just like you do on the earth.
Is there methane up
there or is there CO?
You know, that sort of thing,
because it's a nice long path line
that we get from the sun.
We did change the direction of the
spacecraft after the encounter,
because there is a [inaudible]
object that we've identified
that we could get to and
do data collection on,
and if we hadn't done the change
we wouldn't have been able
to do it later on.
Now, there's still we have to write
a proposal and it has to be accepted
and da, da, da, da, da, da, to, you
know, actually do that measurement.
So we're not saying we're doing
that, but we did the change
because if we didn't do that
it would become a moot point.
So, work remaining lot.
We got about thirty
percent of the data down.
Most you guys might not remember
this, but back in the day
when we had modems that
connected us to the internet,
remember the 300 [inaudible] modems.
>> Right.
>> Because that's the speed
the data's coming out, right.
[ Laughs ]
>> So, you know, you just
saw lines go like this,
that's the speed the
data's coming down
and we have gigabytes
worth of data, right.
So it takes a while
and that's physics.
It's far away, we can't
have the big radiator,
we don't have a huge
amount of power,
just takes that long
to get stuff out.
We still have some optimization
on the data from the instruments.
There can be artifacts and that's
why we're doing that calibration
to make sure that nothing has
changed in the time before
and after we went to Pluto.
We still have to co-register all
the data from all the instruments,
so that we know exactly, yes,
when this is seeing that,
that was seeing this, we're looking
at different angles of things
because not only do
particles, the composition
of particles change how they
absorb light, it's the shape
and the size of particles.
And once you start getting particles
that are sort of the same size
as the wavelength of light, they
have different characteristics
than bigger or smaller particles.
And then now we have to go and
do our combine modeling, right.
We have to take the data that we've
got that we trust and then go into,
say, well, what is the
geophysical composition all thermal
of da, da, da, da, da.
In other words, explain
what's going on.
What is the dynamics
that's going on?
How is it coupled?
Why are we seeing this
flat area that's smooth?
Is that something that's going
to go away after a while?
And by the way, as Pluto
moves away from the sun,
the atmosphere is starting
to condense
and the fact we thought
it would be --
we were afraid it was going to be
gone by the time we got out there,
the fact that it's still
there's, it's nice.
Let's put it that way.
And If you're interested in
more information there is this.
There's also a photo journal.
Every time I've tried
to copy the address
of the photo journal it would
mess everything else up,
so I said all right.
You guys can just go to
New Horizons photo journal
and you see these images.
But these is the places to
go to get the data from.
Now, what time is it?
>> 12:30
>> Ooh, Jesus.
Okay so I got a little bit of time.
What this is, is this is a
Ralph centric image of movie
of what was going on at Pluto, what
was happening during the encounter.
So remember what I said was
we have these fields of view.
I'm looking at you, you're Pluto and
now if I want to take the spectrum
of you I have to scan my field of
view plus you, and I'm going to go
over there and look at you because
you're Charon and do the same thing
and you're KERBEROS, so
I'm going to do that.
And so I have to move around and
I have to change the orientation
of things and I have to do that,
so that if I take data with Ralph
that I can now also take data
with Lorri at the same time
or with the Alice spectrometer,
and by the way trying to explain
to people of a certain
age, what the relationship
between Ralph and Alice
is has been --
[ Laughs ]
>> -- a joy for the last ten years.
At any rate, so there's a lot of
activity going on and all that had
to be planned, because it
takes four hours for light
to get from the earth to Pluto.
Hours for information to get back.
So if I said "Okay now start to
take data," it would say "Oh, well,
to bad I'm already past," Right.
Because remember the closest
approach really was hours.
We're going 10,000 kilometers,
excuse me, ten kilometers a second,
right, so, you know,
3,000 kilometers an hour.
You go and buy something
where you're getting
up to 10,000 kilometers with it,
that is much less of an hour,
so you have to have everything
well planned and you have
to know where things are.
That was another thing is that
we were concerned for a while
that maybe Pluto was not
quite where we thought it was.
And so we had this big plan
where we take all these data
and it wouldn't be a Pluto so you'd
have to put in more margin and then
that means you take less data
because you have to
scan more and so on.
So what this is it shows you what
happened during the encounter,
at least as far as
Ralph is concerned.
These long lines are the 5,000
pixel wide MVIC detector.
And we scan that across to
get color and [inaudible].
You also see a square one, that's
the Leisa field of view, okay.
So if I'm lucky and
it worked earlier.
So, okay, so now this is, oops,
let me get this out of the way.
This is ninth of July.
Now, you see we're taking some
measurements, here's the tenth
of July we're taking
some more measurements.
That's the a Leisa field of view
and you're really not
feeling much of it, right.
The resolution is not that
great, but we're taking data
because we're getting
different phase angles,
we're getting different
information about this.
So there is information
in here that's important.
Now we're up to the 13th, so we went
to the ninth till the 13th
in that period of time.
Now we're on the 14th, now
we're going to sit on the 14th
for quite a while, but
look what's happening.
Look at all these operations
that are going out,
and we're doing things like going
the opposite way to get flat field,
and we're scanning,
there's a scan of Pluto,
there's two of our high
resolution scans of Pluto.
There's one of our high
resolution scans of Charon.
And I'm not expecting
you to follow all this.
[ Laughs ]
Just get the idea, there's
a lot going on here.
This was all planned, you
know, well, not well before,
continually as we go to
Pluto, as we did practice,
as we found out what actually occur.
Now you can also see that remember
how the objects were much smaller
than the detectors, now all of the
sudden those detectors are smaller
than the objects, so we've
gone like a factor of a 1,000
in spacial resolution in that
period, that's impressive.
Now we're about leaving.
This is still on the
14th, we're leaving,
we're still on the 14th
we're still taking data's
as we go out, now on the 15th.
All that time in the middle was
all the operations that were going
on in the 14th, so when I say
that this was a team effort
where the planners and everybody,
you know, to get that right,
and the fact that we did
get it right was amazing.
And that picture I showed you was
the one that showed the haze layers,
you know, with the mountains and
everything, that had to be done
in a very specific way, because
a lot of times we could just sort
of fire the thrusters
and scan across
and didn't have to
worry about things.
But as we got real close to Pluto,
now the spacecraft motion
got coupled to the motion
that you're doing with the scan,
and so I have to change
things at the same rate.
So now you have to not
only know where you are,
but you have to know how fast
you're going when you go by,
and put that into how you're doing
the scan or else you smear things,
and they did a wonderful job.
So I think actually --
>> Wait, yeah, I'm sure
there are colleagues
with lots of questions, right?
>> And but I did it, I got --
>> Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughs ]
>> And I'm very much
appreciating you taking the time.
[ Applause ]
>> And with the questions
if you can try
to repeat the questions
for the video.
>> Okay.
>> Okay, questions...
>> You mentioned thrusters, what
was the mechanism for pointing
and moved the whole craft?
>> That's right.
There were lot of little rocket
motors, basically thrusters
that move the spacecraft around.
Now in a lot of times you'll
have, you know, spinning objects
that can move the thing around,
but here we didn't have the
[inaudible] thank you I couldn't
remember the name.
But here we didn't have the power
or the capability of doing that,
so we had to use the thrusters.
So you fire a little thruster and
it start moving the thing and then
when you got up to the speed
you wanted you stopped firing
the thrusters.
>> And you have enough fuel in the
thrusters for all this [inaudible]?.
>> That's right.
And for what would happen later on.
Yes.
>> When Charon was discovered it
considered to be a moon of Pluto,
is it still a moon of
Pluto or is it considered
to be two planets that
orbit each other?
>> That's an excellent question
and the answer is the latter.
They're all orbiting a central
mass location, so if you noticed
when you saw the orbits on
that movie I was showing you,
it looks kind of weird
they didn't look circular.
That's because they were based
on the position of Pluto,
and as Pluto moves around it moves
around the center of gravity,
as do those other moons, so if
you plot something with respective
to the center of Pluto it sort
of distorts what the
other guys look like.
Yes, they're considered to be
at least a binary system now
of [inaudible] decimal
system, [inaudible] system.
Yes.
>> With the atmospheric it
was recently announced I guess
that [inaudible] had found on the
comet some oxygen, were they testing
for oxygen on New Horizons as well?
>> We would love to.
The problem with oxygen is it's
not really a strong absorber.
Now, possibly some of
the, although I doubt it,
possibly some of the plasma
instruments might be able
to look for it.
But we'll see, you know.
It was a surprise and it's not
something that we expected at all
and I'd be surprised
if it were Pluto,
but then Pluto surprised me, so.
Yes.
>> How long does it
[inaudible] earth?
>> So we started taking, let's
say from the closest approach,
basically we're started taking
data down the day after, you know,
the 15th of July, it's
still coming down.
We're expecting it to come
done through next summer.
All right.
So it's still another six eight
months before it's all down.
Yeah.
>> The data --
>> Oh, I'm sorry I'm not repeating
your question, I'm sorry about that.
>> The data transmission
coming back,
is there any problem with noise?
>> So the question
is there is a problem
with noise interrupting the
data transmission coming back.
And the answer is as always there
is, because we're taking data
into various locations around
the world and if there happens
to be rain at one of those places
you can't necessarily get the data
down, so you have to dump
it down some later time,
where there can be some
mechanical problem that causes you
or electrical problem that
causes you to skip something,
so you do another transmission.
You know, that's something
that we're always planning on.
As far as actually sort
of electronic noise,
it's been pretty good so far.
>> But nothing like
with solar particles?
>> : No, not yet.
Yes.
>> What's the trade off when you
have to go to a certain speed
to get there within a [inaudible],
but what would have
been your options?
How slow could you have gone
so that you could extend the
orbit of Pluto [inaudible]?
>> So the question is how slow
would we have to go to orbit Pluto.
And the answer is real slow.
The problem is that, so remember
that rocket when it took off,
that's getting us out of
the gravitational field
of the earth and its environment.
Well, to stop at Pluto
you'd basically have to have
that rocket go in the
opposite direction, right.
So kind of you need something
that's large to slow you down,
at that rate to slow you down.
So you can imagine that if you went
slower you wouldn't need that big
of a rocket, but still you
got to launch that rocket.
So it's just really not practical
to orbit as we do it with chemicals.
Now, it maybe that we can use
solar or electric propulsion,
start something, take a long
time to get out there, you know,
and just continually throw
us backwards as we go,
but that would be a
whole different study.
Yes.
>> Probably this is not a
very sophisticated question,
but in the beginning you
were showing a picture
of the Hubble telescope and if the
Hubble can take pictures of galaxies
that are thousands and
thousands of light years away,
why could it not take close ups
for you from the body that's
in the hundreds of
millions say of miles away?
>> So the question is why can the
Hubble take pictures of objects
that are very far away, but when
it looked at Pluto it didn't have
that much facial resolution.
Well, if you look at a Hubble
picture of a star it's a point,
you don't see any resolution.
If you look up in a Hubble
picture of a galaxy, well,
Pluto is 2,000 kilometers,
2,400 kilometers in diameter.
Galaxy is a 100,000
light years, right.
So if I'm looking at
light at an angle,
even if it's far away makes
it reasonably good angle,
so I can see something
over that area.
Pluto is very, very sub arch second.
You know, much lower resolution
than most objects on telescopes
on the ground and barely, just
barely what the Hubble can do
and that's why it's only
a few pixels across.
Yes sir.
>> When does it finally
run out of power?
>> That's a good question.
I've seen various plots and the
ideas that well, as we go further
out you don't have to run the
spectrometers or the images
because there's nothing to see,
so you can back off power there,
you can back off power on other
things and perhaps only run the ion,
you know, and the student dust
counter and things like that.
I believe the estimate,
and don't quote me on this,
but I believe the estimate
is somewhere in the mid 20s,
30s that we start to get to
the point where, you know,
we just even can't transmit the
data back anything like that.
Yes.
>> Me?
>> Yes, ma'am.
>> Okay. I just want to say I
was lucky enough to participate
in NASA's social event at John
Hopkins and I got to meet a lot
of the team, Dr. [inaudible]
and Dr. Green who said,
you're right it's 20, 30 because
he said once you start backing off
as just be fascinating,
like, in 2006 it launched
and just seeing all the images
that making Pluto now
seem more interesting
than it was than just an icy body.
So I want to cause
trouble, are you team planet
or team small icy object?
[ Laughs ]
>> So here's the person who's
trying to cause trouble,
basically asking me if I think
it's a planet or an icy dwarf.
So I actually did, there's a thing
on the Internet called
four questions and answers.
My answer there was I don't think
Pluto cares what we call them.
[ Laughs ]
>> And the reality is that it's
part of a new set of objects
that just are going to tell
us huge amounts of data.
Whether you call it a planet or
an icy planet or a dwarf planet,
that's a convention, right.
It's, you know, they used to call,
if you look at astrology I
believe the earth is not a planet,
but the sun is, right.
You know, there are
conventions that go into things.
It's up to you.
I just think it's exciting to go
out there and see these things,
you know, they tell
us about what we are.
>> Well done.
>> I've been practicing.
[ Laughs ]
>> Any other questions?
Yes, sir.
>> While the data is
still coming in,
we don't know your talk will be
looking forward to next summer
after the rest of it comes
in, but I'm curious the things
that you're seeing
and the bizarre things
that you're seeing we can't test
with New Horizons what you would
like to see from what you seen so
far on New Horizons two whenever
that might be in the next 200 years?
>> Well, so then you guys can
push for New Horizons two.
Obviously, I probably won't
be all that involved in it.
I think what you'd basically
do is have perhaps very similar
instruments, but they be much more
capable now because, you know,
we have bigger arrays, we
can do more wavelengths.
We would like to cover
more wavelengths.
We might want to put on a
mass [inaudible] something
that can tell us what's there.
It would be very nice, and
we'd actually had in one
of the many plans something
that would go to the surface.
Right now, it doesn't have
to land gently or, you know,
maybe we can make it so it's an
impact or as long as some parts
of it is -- that would be something
that I think would be extraordinary.
Now, the opposite side of that is
every time we have one of those
that goes into an atmosphere,
we find out that its going
into some unique place right.
You know, so it's not necessarily
represented of everything,
but if we could see the surface
that would be really nice.
And that's something,
excuse me, that you can do
without a huge amount
of back throws,
because it's a small object, right.
So you just have to
stop it, you don't have
to stop the 500 kilometer thing you
have, or excuse me, kilogram thing,
you just have to stop the
two kilogram thing and now
with technology we can make that
a very capable two kilograms.
And you had a question.
>> Can you say something
more about the atmosphere
and the specification
how does this impact
and planning how it affected
the instruments, what they read
and so forth I think
is a critical thing,
but wasn't it that whole
atmosphere assumed to be gaseous
or semi gaseous on the
surface or whatever.
>> So the question is how did
the structure of the atmosphere
or the proposed assumed structure of
the atmosphere affect the planning
for the Pluto mission
from the very beginning.
>> The precipitation that was
coming out of [inaudible].
>> Yes.
So the precipitation is
still its only coming
from a few hundred
kilometers up and we only get
to within 10,000 kilometers,
so we didn't worry
about it in terms of danger.
Now in terms of what
we would like to see,
how we would do the observations,
remember I mentioned that we have
that radar, or excuse
me, the radio instrument
and also the other instruments
that we could take data
as we went behind the system.
We were worried that if we didn't
get out there early enough.
One of the reasons we were
pushing for the 2006 launch was
that the atmosphere would be gone.
So it really drove more our
impetus to get the launch as soon
as we possibly could than
anything, you know else.
The instruments were going
to be pretty much what the
instruments were going to be
because we were going to look for
-- if there was less atmosphere,
we' were still going
to look for the things
that we expected to
be in the atmosphere?
>> How soon will the
atmosphere totally [inaudible]?
>> Well, that's very hard to tell,
because again, we kind of thought
that it would be gone by now.
Now, we were doing
measurements [inaudible]
if a star goes behind Pluto,
you know it doesn't shut
the light off immediately.
You can kind of see
it slowly go down,
but you see atmosphere is
scattering light and we could tell
that the atmosphere was still
there and it surprised us.
So if there is a, you know, a
mechanism that's causing convection
and causing evaporation
still from the surface well,
if that can maintain
and the atmosphere can maintain even
though it's not necessarily near
the sun.
A lot of -- also what we're seeing
is that the colors of things,
you know, so if you got a black
surface it absorbs more light,
it gets hotter, the sputnik plantum,
that flat area is very white,
well that may be a
reason why it's cold.
It's also kind of never really
gets the sun on it directly, so,
you know, that may be why
it's still producing things
or condensing things
from the atmosphere.
So stuff may be coming from
other places and coming there,
and forming that flat area.
So did that answer your question?
Okay. Any others?
One more.
>> You have an object that's
over a billion years old
[inaudible] several billion?
>> Yeah.
>> And you were concerned that
the atmosphere might be gone
or delayed a couple of more years?
>> So remember this
thing orbits, right.
And Pluto has a very
elliptical orbit,
so it gets actually
inside the orbit of Neptune
for part of the time, okay.
So the feeling was well, when you're
close to the sun you get warmth
and that's going to cause
the atmosphere to come up.
Now as you go far out,
now it gets very cold
and the atmosphere condenses, so
the perihelion was 1988 or something
like that, I forgotten exactly.
That's when it closest to the sun.
As It goes out, it's
just getting colder.
We thought that we
better get out there soon.
Anything else?
>> Yes.
>> Well again thank
you very much for --
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.